how many of you are fans of the show
[Applause]
say his name you guys know the words
[Music]
what's up
it's good to be here my name is Hans Kim
and I'm pretty good at fingering
[Music]
whenever I see a dude not washing his
hands on the bathroom I'm like good
that's 10 for your fingers that I have
to worry about
whenever I see a woman squirming around
in her seats I'm like you shouldn't have
gotten fingered by some dirty ass
homeless dude
[Music]
so I got that Sriracha [__] right now
tired of fingering girls in yoga pants
it's like a resistance band
it's in La recently a lot of snowflakes
there woke people who are like no means
no when a girl says stop you gotta stop
and then they get to a four-way stop and
just blow through the stop sign
foreign
congratulations you're a rapist
all right that's my time thank you thank
you it is indeed 59.5 seconds from the
professional Hans Kim are you the person
that signed up from China tonight
I'm American just like you Tony I know I
know my sweetheart how about another
hand for Hans Kim everybody
doing it again
easy breezy making it look easy I love
it love the stop sign joke how do you
feel how do you feel that it went I felt
it went all right I felt like uh you
know maybe the crowd is like racist
against Chinese people wow
look at that I'm Korean
we love it Ty you know Hans Kim what do
you think about all this I love Hans
I've known Hans since he was still in
Washington uh before he got into the van
yeah
I uh don't remember that part but
I think I would have remembered you yeah
Ty may be roofied you and butt [__] the
[__] out of you and that's why you don't
remember
oh last time Hans told me he was
homophobic so that might be why I love
you I don't like the others but
you don't like what the others
the other what the gays oh really is
that true yeah wow oh my goodness what
is it about the gays that you don't like
Hans brutally honest almost autistic
Hans Kim
they're like strong like a man but they
like gossip like a woman so
I can't hurt them you can't hurt them
the gays like getting fingered too Hans
oh really is there like lube for that or
usually just spit oh
[Music]
oh boy
Hans uh what's been going on this week
tell us about it it's always so
interesting to find out about your real
life I went to LA with my girlfriend we
got an Airbnb we stayed there for five
days she got only mad at me twice so
that was okay let's go over what were
the two times what did she get mad at
you about this is always interesting one
time she just remembered the fact that I
uh wore a girl's shirt that was her
naked on it so she was like oh remember
that time I'm mad at you for that now
you didn't even wear it when in L.A she
just had a memory yeah
I thought like I'm an Entertainer you
know I do crazy things like you know
wear porn on my shirt
what was the second thing she got mad
about some girls snapchatted me and uh
you know I'm not interested in her Cara
I uh
[Music]
I don't care about her
how did your girlfriend find out that
another girl snapchatted you she
probably looked at my phone
[Applause]
she probably looked at your phone what
do you mean she probably looked at your
phone huh I mean she probably like
looked at the notification the home
screen she doesn't have my passcode yet
so ah I love how you said yet why do you
have notifications turned on for
Snapchat on your home screen oh you can
turn that off
oh my God you are just a magnet for
trouble it is unbelievable what other
notifications do you have turned on I
have Tick Tock I have uh Instagram I
have I have everything turned on why do
you think you have everything turned on
except for your girlfriend
[Laughter]
[Applause]
foreign
because my dick isn't as big as she
wants it to be
[Laughter]
just Hans being Hans up here anything
else you want to talk about Hans what
else is going on in life no challenges
this week no challenges for next week oh
yeah that was uh pretty stressful for me
last week I challenged Brian redband's
girlfriend and uh it was kind of
humiliating I feel like my girlfriend
should challenge Brian redband for his
job now wow
oh my goodness
I want her looking at my phone over here
though
uh what else is going on in life Hans
anything else
um I'm STD free wait when did you get
when did you find this out it was like a
while ago I said it on the show but I'm
still STD free how do you know you're
still STD free if you didn't get another
test because my girlfriend is the only
person I've been having sex with and I
hope she's been faithful to me
I don't think she is probably like if I
were to has there been anything
suspicious do you feel like she has
perhaps cheated on you no she did have
dinner with her ex tonight and her mom's
but wait what why is she having dinner
with her ex tonight because he needed
his bed back she was sleeping in his bed
she was sleeping in his bed yeah she he
let her borrow her his bed
dinner together I don't know uh her mom
his mom was there and she likes his mom
she's apparently like dying
so oh geez whatever wow sounds
suspicious as [__] the old dying Mom oh
she went and took a nap because she's
dying and we just had dinner he feasted
all right the madness just said they
[__] in the back I just heard him say
it just still let you know and he has he
has extra senses that we don't have
you can he can feel the vibration of
your girlfriend's former bed right now
why did they break up originally like
what was the reason for them to break up
I think that he was just like a loser
just not doing anything with his life
and
your girlfriend does cocaine and nitrous
like
that is true
that's just high standards Hans Funtime
sometimes Hans you did it again and way
to get the show started that's a minute
from the great Hans Kim everything thank
you for getting us started tonight
the show's nuts we pull names out of a
bucket and then they get brought to us
from The Other Bar Next Door